you know fire investigators in southern
Russia are trying to establish the cause
of an explosion at a petrol station at
least 35 people were killed in Dagestan
children among the 80 injured the fire
started at a car repair shop in the
regional capital and then spread to the
petrol station next door let's bring in
Yulia shop of Oliver she joins us from
Moscow on this Julia tell us more about
this blast and what's going on there
right now
yeah as you said the cause of the blast
in pakistanis are known as being
investigated at the moment we can speak
about 35 dead and as many as
110 people injured that's according to
the local emergency services the
authorities of Dagestan have introduced
a state of emergency in the kumtor
Kolinski District after the explosion
and today is the day of mourning in the
Republic the explosion happened on the
outskirts of dagestan's capital
mahajkala as a car repair shop as you
said first according to preliminary
reports a gas cylinder exploded on one
of the cars and then the blast calls the
fire which spread to the nearby petrol
station and there till the eight fuel
tanks exploded and it caused a massive
fire at reached 600 square meters but by
morning it was extinguished but as you
see the destruction area is huge there
and obviously it will take time to
tackle all the consequences how are the
authorities handling this right now
well the
dad and all the victims the Emergency
Services uh playing right now understand
has landed in mahatchikala a criminal
case has been launched into the case
citing services that do not meet safety
requirements there and as I said August
the 15th in Dagestan is declared a day
of mourning for the victims of the
explosion the families of the victim was
were promised to be paid one million
Rubles each that's about ten and a half
thousand dollars but I should say that
prior to that tragedy some spontaneous
protesters took place in the region due
to the lack of water and electricity in
people's houses so the situation among
local population was quite tense even
before the tragedy and now this tragedy
happened as well
Julia shop of Oliver reporting there
from Moscow thank you very much